la sphère de gaston dominici l'histoire
de ce triple meurtre d'un couple
d'anglais et de leur fille revue et peut
être corrigé par des étudiants de droit
de l'université de versailles saint
quentin c'est le projet lancé par
l'association juriste tribune
tous les ans une reconstitution de
procès est proposé on choisit une une
affaire qui dont le jugement a été son
risque obscures dans le sens où les
preuves ne montre pas vraiment la
culpabilité ou l'innocence de l'accusé
est donc en fait notre rôle c'est de
vraiment faire tout un dossier pour pour
essayer de trouver les petites erreurs
pour essayer vraiment de construire
quelque chose de solide pour montrer aux
étudiants comment se déroule un procès
la préparation commence dès le mois
d'octobre
dans un premier temps trouver toutes les
preuves et les informations liées à ce
dossier
on se bat surtout sur internet on
souhaite surtout de trouver ça qu'on
trouve pas tout ce qu'on veut par
exemple pour les procès verbaux
d'audition de toutes les personnes en
arrêt s'être à en trouver quelques uns
comme celui l'accusé ou celui d'un des
témoins mais c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas à
les pièces ne sont pas toutes ouvertes
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut pas aller voir
les scellés par me défends nous demande
l'épreuve est ce que vous avez les
vraies preuves banon c'est des preuves
pas qu'on essaye de retranscrire au
mieux on n'a pas remporté allons dans
cette affaire là est important d'en bas
qui viennent chez nous mais c'est le but
est vraiment d'essayer de retranscrire
au mieux pour les étudiants dans un
deuxième temps il faut préparer lé rôle
de chargé de travaux dirigés joue le
rôle des avocats le président du jury
est représenté par un professeur
les jurés sont des personnes extérieures
à l'université et des étudiants de droit
eux sont les témoins on est nouveau dans
en première année donc on connaît rien
et donc là on touche un peu à tout on
augmente nos capacités à réfléchir sur
le droit et donc ça c'est une ouverture
en plus à l'époque et gaston dominici
avait été jugé coupable et condamné à
mort
soixante et un ans plus tard le verdict
sera-t-il différent
réponse vendredi lors de la
reconstitution qui aura lieu au tribunal
de grande instance de versailles
l'an passé juris tribune avait d'étudier
une autre affaire célèbre le procès
ranucci les étudiants n'avaient alors
pas condamné christian ralenti à la
peine de mort mais à la prison à
perpétuité
autres temps autres moeurs
juridique